emmanuel macron déplacement à amiens sa
ville natale une visite qui intervient à
cinq mois de la présidentielle le chef
de l'état doit notamment évoquer le
suivi des grands chantiers de
développement de la ville et du
territoire emmanuel macron qui devra
affronter la colère des sages-femmes en
grève précisions sur place de notre
reporter est elle fâche
les sages femmes sont en colère et elle
compte bien le faire savoir ici à venir
elles sont rassemblés devant le rectorat
de la ville car depuis le 18 novembre
elle la maternité si damien et fair milk
conséquences d'une grève entamée par les
sages-femmes le 22 octobre dernier elle
réclame des revalorisations salariales
et plus est d'effectifs un rassemblement
auquel s'est joint le député de la somme
françois ruffin vous propose de
l'écouter
les soignants du pays sont dans le mal
être pour une raison simple c'est qu'ils
ont le sentiment de mal faire leur
travail de le faire en ayant à leur oeil
sur la montre et c'est le cas des sages
femmes qui font quoi qui courent d'un
accouchement suivant et quand il y en a
un qui devient compliqué basse et une
femme enceinte qui se retrouve à être
toute seule même si elles appuyé sur la
sonnette pendant une heure elle et
laisser tout seul dans son coin tout
n'est pas une question de salaire ou de
rénovation des bâtiments c'est comment
on permet aux gens de faire leur travail
du mieux possible et aujourd'hui on a
des hôpitaux qui craque alors c'est le
cas à amiens c'est le cas à abbeville
c'est le krach à creil c'est le cas à
senlis pour la picardie c'est le cas à
péronne bon mais c'est pareil dans tout
le pays pourquoi parce que les soignants
sont découragés parce qu'ils ont ce
sentiment de mal faire leur travail et
ça pour l'instant le pouvoir le
ministère de la santé ne le comprend pas
et quand il rappelé réponse salaires
rénovation le bâtiment ils passent à
côté de l'essentiel les sages-femmes qui
avait demandé à s'entretenir avec le
chef de l'état elles sont en ce moment
reçu à la préfecture d'amiens par le
cabinet l'elysée